équipez vous sans vous ruiner
voilà le mot d'ordre lancé par la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour écouler
son mobilier
suite à son déménagement de montigné
attrape particularité il s'agit d'une
vente aux enchères la quatrième du genre
depuis le mois de juin
il faut s'inscrire c'est gratuit et
ensuite on sélectionne les biens qui
nous intéresse et on enchérit alors par
pas de 10% des prix affichés et à la fin
de l'enchère donc le dernier
enchérisseur le meilleur enchérisseur
est déclarée enchérisseurs également
nous avons l'intention de déménager
donc on va avoir entre 66 m² on passe à
donc évidemment il nous faut il faut
remplir
on va voir une très très grande pièce
qui va nous servir du bureau donc on
cherche des petits meubles pas trop cher
donc ici faut reconnaître que les prix
d'appel sont quand même intéressant
ouverte le 5 septembre cette vente aux
enchères concernent aussi quatre
voitures des tables de cantine et des
luminaires ici les personnes intéressées
peuvent voir en vrai le mobilier mis en
vente
on a vu ça sur internet par hasard un
petit peu et puis ben du coup ça nous a
donné envie de venir voir quand même
avant de faire des enchères de voir
quand même un petit peu l'état du
matériel parce que sur les photos très
très bien quand même
il a fallu inventorié répertoriés et
photographier tout le mobilier un
travail laborieux mais payant les trois
premières vagues ont permis d'écouler
174 éléments le bilan de cette dernière
vente sera connu le 16 septembre date de
clôture des enchères